[Music]
on this Tuesday night no to a public
inquiry into foreign interference David
Johnston's long-awaited conclusions a
public review of classified intelligence
simply cannot be done is
economic time there is a lot at stake
what's pushing business away from the
province a cold case in Quebec cracked
how police finally figured out who
killed this teenager in 1975.
and one family's fight so their little
boy can hear hearing shouldn't be for
the privileged
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us former
Governor General David Johnston has
ruled out the need for a public inquiry
into foreign interference in Canada's
Democratic process Johnston who was
asked by prime minister Justin Trudeau
to investigate whether an inquiry is
necessary has concluded there is no
question foreign governments are
attempting to influence political
candidates and voters and more needs to
be done to combat it but he says because
so much of the information is top secret
there's no way to air it in public
the intelligence I have reviewed is and
must remain Secret
as a result the reality is any credible
public inquiry would not be public at
all
in his report Johnson also concluded I
have not found examples of ministers the
prime minister or their offices
knowingly ignoring intelligence advice
or recommendations on foreign
interference or being driven by partisan
considerations in dealing with these
issues and he addressed the leaks of
classified information to the media that
he says are destructive and dangerous
and he says it is a matter of urgency
that the leakers be caught citing
unnamed National Security sources Global
News and the Globe and Mail have
reported on a range of influence and
interference operations by the Chinese
government particularly during the 2019
and 2021 elections Johnston has spent
the last two months reviewing talk
secret documents and interviewing
politicians including the Prime Minister
who said today he will abide by the
recommendations our coverage tonight
begins with David Aiken in Ottawa David
well Donna former Governor General David
Johnson said he started his work
thinking he would recommend a public
inquiry into foreign interference but
after reviewing dozens of top secret
memos on the topic he concluded a public
inquiry was neither needed nor would one
even be possible a separate public
inquiry will simply not deliver the
lever of transparency
and urgency Canadians expect Johnston
was also asked to determine if the prime
minister or any ministers were negligent
in failing to act on allegations of
foreign interference his conclusion they
were not I have found no examples of
ministers the prime minister or their
offices knowingly or negligently failing
to act on intelligence advice or
recommendations on the issues I have
investigated related to the 2019 and
2021 elections Johnston's harshest
judgment was for Canada's security
agencies and their failure to manage and
share information in a way that the
important stuff got to the desks of
ministers and the Prime Minister we have
much to do to be much more effective
much more professional much more
harmonized Johnson also notes that he
would not have produced his report
addressing these important issues had it
not been for reporting by global news
and the Globe and Mail reporting that
was often based on intelligence leaked
from ceases and other National Security
sources Johnson said those media reports
created what he called quote
misapprehensions because he said the
leaked information was taken out of
context the specific instances of
interference Johnson said are less
concerning than some media reporting has
suggested and in some cases the story is
quite different for example Johnson
referred to a report by global news
alleging that Toronto MP Han dong
counseled the Chinese Diplomat to delay
the release of the two Michaels Johnson
said that allegation is false and it's
an allegation dong had denied in a
statement dong said he felt Vindicated
by Johnson's report Johnson came to his
conclusion after reviewing the same
intelligence report the Prime Minister
saw Global News has not confirmed the
contents of that intelligence report or
whether it contained leaked information
provided to Global News from two
national security sources Johnson
confirmed what dong said at the time
dong did speak to the Chinese Diplomat
about the Michael case but dong said he
was advocating for their release that
was a conversation the pmo never knew
about until the global news report dong
has filed a lawsuit against Global News
and its parent company chorus
entertainment in response to the
reporting Johnston is also the latest
authority to certify the validity of the
2019 and 2021 elections that despite
attempts by Foreign states to interfere
none have had any impact on electoral
outcomes Donna okay David Aiken thanks
well this is not put an end to calls for
a public inquiry the leader of the NDP
still says one is needed the leader of
the conservatives who refused to meet
David Johnston continues to say Johnston
can't be trusted to assess the liberal
government's response to allegations of
foreign interference
put his friend his ski buddy
his Cottage neighbor and Trudeau
Foundation member David Johnston in
charge of today's uh
um whitewash attempt conservatives are
not buying it the public inquiry is
necessary I will make that very clear
and I'll make it clear to the Prime
Minister that we're going to use all the
tools that we have at our disposal to
continue to push for one at the federal
level
and with me now is our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes where
does this leave the prime minister
well Donna it's not what the opposition
or some former senior National Security
officials wanted to hear today but the
Prime Minister says there will be no
public inquiry
I committed to listening very carefully
and abiding by the recommendations that
the uh that the former Governor General
made and he explained and Justified his
thought processes by it and we will be
following his recommendations
Trudeau maintains that his government
takes foreign interference seriously and
has taken action on it but the Liberals
still have not introduced a foreign
agent's registry or duplicated tools
that Canada's five eyes allies have put
into place to counter foreign
interference and National Security
sources who came forward to Global News
said they spoke out because they felt
the government wasn't listening to the
intelligence community's warnings
Mercedes the opposition isn't going to
drop this how politically vulnerable are
the Liberals now
well Donna there's no question today's
decision gives the opposition fodder to
continue to attack the Prime Minister a
recommendation for a public inquiry
would have neutralized some of those
attacks instead the liberal government
will have to contend with allegations
they're covering things up however it
does also allow Mr Trudeau to stick to
his talking points and Mr Johnston's
recommendations for voters it might be a
bit of an ink blot test on how they feel
about the government eight years in
Canadians typically don't vote on
National Security issues but successive
scandals can take a toll in voters
decisions
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank
you now to Alberta's election Advance
voting began today for that election
which takes place next Monday UCP leader
Danielle Smith cast her ballot today as
did Alberta NDP leader Rachel notley if
you believe the opinion polls the race
appears to be a tight one the two
leaders have very different Visions for
how to make Alberta's economy Prosper
it's still affected by the boom and bust
of oil prices and Business Leaders
increasingly believe now is the time for
the province to diversify here's Heather
York's West
it's called Nightingale a fantasy video
game title coming soon from inflection
games we are a studio that started in
July of 2018 there was four of us
originally we're up to about 90 here in
Edmonton now the interactive and digital
technology sector is a burgeoning
industry a perfect way for Alberta's
energy heavy economy to diversify except
what began as a good news story for
Alberta has become a story of
opportunity lost inflections last 40
hires have been based in Toronto
Vancouver and Montreal we've decided to
grow outside of Alberta simply because
there's those governments and the tax
policies that they have in place in
other provinces are much more favorable
to growing a game studio so what are you
working on Phil nice says a 2019
decision by the United conservative
government to kill an ndp-era tax credit
for the industry saw the studios plan to
grow in Edmonton Screech to a halt this
is a pivotal time for Alberta there's
there is a lot at stake the NDP is
promising to cut Alberta's small
business tax but plans to pay for many
of its platform promises with a three
percent hike to the province's corporate
tax rate bringing it from 8 to 11
percent still the lowest in Canada
though enough to kill investment
according to the UCP Calgary's Chamber
of Commerce says the next government
needs to focus on targeted tax credits
especially when it comes to clean tech
the reality is we are competing with the
United States with the inflation
reduction Act
signed blast August the ACT offers
billions of dollars in subsidies to
promote the growth of biofuels hydrogen
and carbon capture and storage in the
United States if Canada's energy sector
wants to compete Business Leaders say
both the federal and Alberta Government
will have to step up hard and in fact
you know as we speak a lot of Canadian
clean tech companies are pivoting
towards U.S opportunities because the
IRA gives such clear and
low risk incentives the world as you
know it Teeters on the brink
just like the characters in Nightingale
albertans are navigating a critical time
and the next government will have to
move carefully to prepare for the road
ahead Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
the federal government is revamping
airport security measures a new verified
traveler program involves dedicated
security screening lines at six airports
including Toronto and Vancouver eligible
passengers including Nexus members will
no longer have to take their shoes off
and they can keep laptops and liquids in
their bags the program will be gradually
introduced between June 7th and 21st
a Montreal murder mystery dating back
decades finally solved that's coming up
plus fresh optimism in Alberta's fire
fight
[Music]
now to Alberta's wildfires there's new
satellite imagery that shows how much
smoke is blanketing not just the
province but spreading across North
America some of it reaching into the
United States as far as New York city
that is according to the American
National Weather Service there are some
positive signs though there are fewer
fires burning and rainy weather is
moving into some areas raising hopes for
firefighters and residents who had to
flee their homes neither garcha is in
Fox Creek Alberta hearing from locals
and Crews nitu
Donna this is the second day there has
been heavy rainfall here in Fox Creek
finally after nearly three weeks of
Tinder dry conditions the local fire
chief here says members have been so
happy at one point they laid down in the
parking lot of the department just to
soak in this help from Mother Nature in
what they call an extremely challenging
and exhausting firefight
near Fox Creek firefighters are gaining
ground
like most areas of the province they've
now Seen Rain lower temperatures and
higher humidity we're just worried it
might spark up again but uh I'm pretty
hopeful pretty confident this this will
be the trigger point to bring people
back Fox Creek Fire Chief Brian Davidson
says once this rain gauge reaches a
certain point lifting the now nearly
three-week long evacuation order will be
possible and we're hoping for at least
25 mils of rain before we can start
bringing or considering bringing people
back so I just want to make sure the
town is safe you know I want to make
sure I can bring my children back here
for volunteers like him fighting to
protect this community is personal he
grew up in Fox Creek and says it's been
a difficult few weeks for many it's an
emotional roller coaster is what it is
especially for evacuees like Carol scoby
who's lived in Fox Creek for more than
40 years she says the support from
strangers has been overwhelming the love
caring and compassion
you know very much so
um
there isn't anybody that you can go into
town here and they don't give you a hug
she says seeing this rainfall also helps
bring hope we are so happy that this
rain has come firefighters can
concentrate on the containment lines and
not chasing these wildfires that are
popping up about two hours away in
Yellowhead County Fire officials say the
rain has suppressed fire activity but
they're not letting their guards down
unfortunately on the weekend we are
expecting an uptrend of temperature and
so we may get into something similar to
last week but now that the grass is
green and the trees are leafed out we
don't expect the same conditions as we
did two weeks ago for sure after being
grounded for a few days because of thick
smoke this is a co-pilot seat this
private helicopter pilot contracted by
Alberta Wildfire was able to get back up
in the air to help map the fire
perimeter watching the you know the fire
comes so close to people's homes and
their animals and and Wildlife too and
and watching them get confused and run
in the wrong direction it's it's tough
It's it's hard
back in Fox Creek Fire Chief Davidson
says especially with temperatures
expected to stay low throughout the week
he's confident about his members ability
to drive out the fire threat and welcome
residents back home soon
the fire chief says Flames are still
within about four kilometers of Fox
Creek and even if they do feel
comfortable allowing residents back home
this Wildfire will be in their backyard
for months to come across Alberta
provincial officials say this shift in
weather could be the turning point in an
early yet already unprecedented Wildfire
season Donna I meet you garcha and Fox
Creek Alberta thank you search resumed
ahead a new investigation Into The
Disappearance of Madeleine McCann
in Washington a teenager is in custody
accused of trying to drive through
security barriers near the White House
[Music]
this U-Haul truck tried to Ram through
the barriers last night at Lafayette
Square just outside the White House
grounds no one was hurt a 19-year-old
man was arrested and faces multiple
charges including threatening to kill
kidnap or inflict harm on the president
police say evidence collected from the
truck included a Nazi flag
police have begun searching a Reservoir
in Portugal in the long-running
investigation Into The Disappearance of
Madeleine McCann the British child
vanished while on vacation with her
family 16 years ago Portuguese German
and British officers are scouring an
area in the Algarve 50 kilometers from
Priya Deluge where the three-year-old
went missing in 2007. it's the first
search for her in Portugal in nearly a
decade and was requested by German
police who believe a suspect in the case
was in the area around the time the
toddler vanished 45-year-old German
National Christian Brookner a convicted
rapist who was in jail in Germany was
formally declared a suspect in the
McCann case last year
police in Quebec say new technology
helped them solve a mystery that's
endured almost 50 years Montreal
teenager Sharon Pryor was out meeting
friends when she disappeared in 1975.
two days later she was found dead after
being beaten and raped now as Mike
Armstrong explains what was a cold case
for decades as a resolution
smiles and tears
tiered if this day would ever come
Sharon Pryor's little sisters say they
and their mother even five decades later
are still grieving life has not been
easy
for us since then but Sharon has given
us strength
for the past 48 years and especially
today
the prior family back in March of 1975
lived here in Montreal's Point Saint
Charles Sharon was 16 years old and
headed out on a Saturday evening to meet
friends it should have been a two-minute
walk her body was found four days later
in longei about 10 kilometers away she'd
been beaten and raped over the years
there were tips and leads from time to
time all told there were 122 suspects
but each was a dead end until this month
when police visited the family to tell
them the murder had been solved it was a
very emotional moment lots of laughs of
cries no longer police held on to the
close from the crime scene back in 75 it
was just for blood type but keeping the
clothes is what helped close the case
we're not lucky we just did our job
police in August of 2019 were able to
pull new DNA off the clothes they then
submitted that to genealogy websites and
got back possible family names a little
digging from there turned up a suspect
American Franklin Romine died in 1982.
he was buried in West Virginia earlier
this month his body was exhumed and the
DNA taken from his bones matched to
Sharon's killer Romine had been in and
out of jail for serious crimes including
rape he was also back and forth to
Montreal he was living in Quebec when
Sharon disappeared but was never a
suspect we love you Sharon now may you
truly rest in peace the family says
there is a closure knowing remind can't
kill again there's also hope for other
cold cases well gay police say they
expect the same techniques to help solve
another this year Mike Armstrong Global
News Montreal
clinical costs next in Ontario family's
Financial fight for better funding for
hearing devices
Canada has a wide range of publicly
funded health care services but there
are more which aren't fully covered than
you might think and some families only
discover that in their time of need
Catherine Ward spoke with one family
hoping to get better funding for hearing
devices in Ontario as they face a
lifetime of financial struggle
Grayson Hall knows what the rain sounds
like on the steps of Ontario's
legislature Grayson
and it's a very big deal he was born
profoundly deaf due to genetics that we
didn't know that we
carried Cochlear implants gave Grayson
the gift of sound Grayson
hey
when Erica got pregnant again Tess
showed their unborn child would be just
like big brother unable to hear give
baby brother kisses do you expect your
life your child's life to be one way and
it's not in Ontario an initial set of
Cochlear implants and the surgery to fit
them is covered by The Province but the
devices don't last forever sometimes
they need to be replaced or upgraded the
big ticket item is the actual external
processors a single device would cost
twelve thousand six hundred and sixty
dollars according to one quote Erica
received Grayson needs two pushing the
price above twenty five thousand dollars
before coverage kicks in it's likely his
little brother will need the same the
family doesn't have private insurance
officials say Ontario will cover up to
75 percent of replacement speech
processors through and assistive devices
program however there is a cap it works
out to be about five thousand four
hundred and forty four dollars that's
covered through EP
um and then the rest is out of patient
pocket usually cover average isn't equal
across Canada Saskatchewan's co-pay
program means a family only pays 840
dollars per replacement device in Nova
Scotia the government has been funding
replacements for those in need over the
past several years families can't find
out to be a a bit of a shock when it
comes around to an upgrade so Erica and
her family advocate for change on those
rainy steps praying for a brighter
future we need help affording it because
hearing shouldn't be for the privileged
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the beaumaris marina in
Muskoka Lakes Ontario we'd love to see
our Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you